economía en directo América de Francia
24 por supuesto vamos a hablar de lo que
ocurrió toda esta tormenta política en
el Reino Unido porque evidentemente todo
empezó por el dinero por las políticas
económicas equivocas de alguna manera
que tomó la primera misa británica
Blandón con nosotros en el estudio quien
más sino tú Hola Raúl muy buenos días y
volviendo Además este recibimiento
volviendo volvimos con todo Dani vamos a
hablar entonces de cómo operan los
mercados en Londres pues mire Qué
interesante los principales índices
bursátiles del Reino Unido alcanzaron
máximos de sesión esto antes de que
listros anunciara su renuncia como
primera ministra derribada Desde luego
por su programa económico que conmocionó
a los mercados financieros después
redujeron un poco de esas ganancias
ahora están ganando pero no tanto como
al principio de la jornada miremos Libra
esterlina sube frente al Dólar alrededor
del
0,3%, al tiempo que también se cotizan
mínimos de una semana frente al Euro la
libra en este momento cuesta unos
1,2,60 dólares por unidad ha llegado a
estar en niveles tan bajos que no se
veían hace 40 años después de todo este
terremoto económico si nos vamos para la
bolsa de Londres llegó a ganar hasta el
0,4% al principio de la jornada de este
jueves sin embargo rápidamente borró
esas ganancias ya caía 0,1% hace unos
minutos después de esta intervención que
hizo listros en particular en la bolsa
las acciones también Raúl de los
constructores de viviendas están en
mínimos de varios años y es que esta
dimisión de listroso coincide con
mayores perspectivas de más aumentos en
las tasas de interés que alimentan las
preocupaciones sobre la asequibilidad de
las viviendas toda una crisis toda una
crisis y le pregunto que se espera en
materia de las tasas de interés donde
todo el mundo evidentemente ha tenido la
lupa durante estos últimos meses no esta
semana desde guerra Claro que sí Pues
todos los bancos centrales se han
apostado una sola
Cómo podría decirse esto como una sola
uno objetivo
de tasas y el banco de Inglaterra no es
la excepción al parecer este país está
encaminando a una recesión y eso ha
hecho entonces que el banco de
Inglaterra prevea más aumentos en sus
próximas reuniones en las tasas de
interés que podrían llegar inclusive a
un punto porcentual el próximo mes esto
es bastante agresivo si se tiene en
cuenta el historial Pues de aumentos del
banco de Inglaterra esto en un intento
por hacer lo que casi todos los bancos
centrales del mundo quieren hacer que es
reducir el consumo de esta manera va a
hacer que los precios bajen Hablemos del
origen del problema Dani todo inició
entonces con este polémico plan
presentado por litros hace un mes hace
poco más de un mes que disminuía
impuestos a los más ricos colocaba
generoso subsidios al consumo de energía
pero causó gran controversia y colapsó
los mercados porque esto incluía un
inmenso nivel de endeudamiento en un
país que ya de por sí está bastante
endeudado esto no lo vieron con buenos
ojos en el mercado el banco de
Inglaterra se vio obligado inclusive a
comprar bonos de emergencia esto para
frenar una fuerte liquidación en el
mercado de bonos que amenazaba con
causar estragos en la industria de
pensiones y también en aumentar los
riesgos de recesión en este país y por
supuesto esto derivó en el revolcón
dentro del gabinete entonces después de
que presentara este plan trozo se vio
obligada a abandonar casi todo su
programa a principios de esta semana y
su secretario de Hacienda anterior cuasi
cuarta en que tuvo que dar un paso al
costado el viernes pasado guardan ya
había puesto o había propuesto mejor
recortar a la tasa más alta del impuesto
sobre la renta es decir a los más ricos
pero tuvo que desistir muy pronto de
esta polémica iniciativa entonces
después de despedir a cuartel que era su
amigo cercano también su Aliado otros
anunció que el impuesto de sociedades
iba a aumentar al 25%, esto lo había
pretendido ya su predecesor Boris
Johnson Y revirtió entonces el plan de
congelarlo en el 19%. nombró su
reemplazo ayer mi Hunt quien descartó el
lunes casi todo este plan económico de
Trust y cuarten redujo el vasto esquema
de apoyo energético previsto anunciado
en septiembre eso ya lo había hecho
antes de irse esto Qué pasó pues fue
visto como un histórico cambio de
sentido para tratar de restaurar la
confianza de los inversionistas que ya
están de por sí bastante desconfiados de
este país y hablemos de la inflación
cómo está en ese momento tema que nos
gusta pues los precios continúan su
espiral ascendente en este país el mayor
salto en los precios de los alimentos
desde 1980 llevó la inflación británica
al 10,1% del mes pasado igualando un
máximo de 40 años que ya se había
alcanzado en junio y un nuevo golpe para
los hogares británicos ahora todo esto
es jalonado por los precios de los
alimentos principalmente y de la energía
y hay que decir también que el Reino
Unido tiene una inflación bastante alta
si se compara con sus vecinos de la
Unión Europea en donde está entre el
cinco seis siete por ciento solo el
precio de los alimentos aumentó un 14,5%
el mes pasado respecto al año anterior
Esa es la mayor subida en 40 años y que
hace esto que se espere que el banco de
Inglaterra pues siga subiendo esos tipos
de interés más rápidamente para devolver
a la inflación cuyo objetivo es del 2%.
por si fuera poco Raúl los bancos
británicos se están preparando para un
posible impacto fiscal después de que
una fuente dijera que el nuevo ministro
Jeremy Hunt estaba revisando el recargo
actual sobre las ganancias bancarias
pues es bueno Dani Entonces cuál es la
conclusión ante todo esto fue Raúl la
conclusión es que estamos ante una
economía hacia la recesión
salvando este año Raúl la economía
británica creció un 0,2% mínimo en el
segundo trimestre de este año según la
más reciente revisión de la oficina de
estadísticas ya ellos habían estimado
que en el segundo trimestre el pib se
había contraído un 0,1% y Cuál es la
diferencia aunque aunque la diferencia
de estimación es muy corta la diferencia
es que si suma dos trimestres
consecutivos en negativo se podría estar
hablando de que estaría en una recesión
según Pues los preceptos económicos de
toda la vida pues Dani gracias por toda
la información de Reino Unido toda esta
crisis económica y política en ese país
pero yo lo tengo una cifra la cifra del
día se la tengo yo
4.840 el precio del dólar en Colombia
que pues es un tema que también íbamos a
tocar pero pues obviamente Nos tocó
cambiar todos los planes por lo que
ocurre en Reino Unido pero pues también
hay que poner la lupa eso no hay que
ponerle a la lupa 4.84 eso fue el precio
del cierre de ayer vamos a ver en cuánto
está hoy Ya abrió hace unos pocos
minutos el presidente Gustavo Petro dice
que no es culpa de su gobierno que son
las empresas de petróleo y gas las que
están retirando efectivamente sus
dólares del país pero que tienen que
hacerlo porque tienen que
ponerles más impuestos a ellos para
poder financiar todos los programas
sociales del gobierno ha sido algo
Bastante polémico la reforma tributaria
también ha tenido mucho que ver entonces
pues veremos en cuanto nos quedan los
viajes al extranjero de ahora en
adelante a usted y a mí Daniela Bueno
muchísimas gracias Dani como siempre por
toda la información